what up space fam goes in here from
anime uproar and i'm back at it again to
discuss the latest crazy and in this
case
unbelievably tragic developments in the
boruto story
if you do enjoy seeing these boruto chat
reviews on the channel then show
boruto some love by smashing that like
button if you haven't be sure to
subscribe
and this is crucial hit that
notification bell and select
all or you will miss future boruto
videos and while you wait for the next
insane chapter to drop
feel free to check out my growing naruto
slash boruto playlist where i got
videos on all of tsutsuki all uzumaki
all
kage and much more link to that is in
the description now without further ado
let's jump into it spoilers and all
so on the cover of this one we got a
colored image of code from cara
a follower of ishikiyotutsuki clearly
this red haired dude is the new villain
to look out for
but more on him later let me know how
you like his aesthetic
since he does have a pretty interesting
design so this chapter starts with
naruto's inner world he looked dead in
the last chapter
so here we're going to figure out what's
actually going on is our boy lost
forever like i kept saying i don't think
that's ever gonna happen
without a hundred year time skip or
something like that but let's keep going
naruto and kurama talk naruto assumes
that they're talking here because he's
dying
kurama says he came to say farewell and
says this may be our last conversation
so start talking naruto obviously this
doesn't sound
good but that maybe is hopeful if
nothing else
naruto begins with the big elephant in
the room he starts with saying that
kurama
killed his father and mother but then he
stops himself despite the fact that
kurama did end up causing the death of
his parents
naruto chooses to focus on their bond
the fact that they've been through a lot
together
and he says all in all he's glad kurama
was around
it's crazy to think how far kurama has
come and these words of naruto show that
he recognizes and appreciates that
too although naruto had ample reason to
hate kurama
he didn't and as a result kurima ended
up helping him
so much over the years kuruma asks if
that's all he's got to say
putting naruto on the spot clearly
naruto is not so prepared
to die even though he thought he was
he's got no idea what to say
no final words prepared finally we
figure out that kurama
is the one that's actually going to go
while naruto will be fine
i mentioned this possibility in previous
chapter reviews because kurima
specifically
said one of us may die at one point and
at this point i thought he might be
referring to himself
and that appears to be the price of
baryon mode it's not the same as
naruto dying but this is still
unbelievably
tragic even more so because kuruma has
gotten to the point where he cares
enough about naruto that he'd sacrifice
his own life to help him out this
is a recurring idea in naruto when you
actually show kindness friendship and
trust to a seemingly bad guy
he'll often surprise you as was the case
with gara too what often turns people
into villains is loneliness and thus
friendship and compassion can actually
turn them into good guys
at least some of the time kurama has
been with us and naruto for so long
it's heartbreaking to see him go this is
definitely one of the most
tragic deaths in naruto and let me know
if there are any that you'd put above
this shattering one
what you gotta respect about kurama is
that he was ready to atone for his past
yeah he caused death and destruction but
eventually he saved the son of minato
and kushina and even the entire village
in a way of looking at it kurama
explains that normally if a bijou is
extracted from ajinchuriki
they will die but this doesn't apply to
naruto the chakra simply vanishes
now in theory tailed beasts would come
back eventually
even if their jin churiki died however
kurma is implying here that baryon mode
might prevent this from happening
he did say this may be the last time we
speak
so there is seemingly a chance of him
coming back somehow
but right now it definitely seems like
we're seeing the last of him and that is
heartbreaking
i'm probably gonna say that way too many
times but it is even though kurima
doesn't like getting too affectionate
it's clear that naruto meant the world
to him and that's one of the reasons
this is so hard to experience
kurima explains that the price of baryon
mode was his life and not naruto's he
never planned to sacrifice naruto's life
kuruma misled him because he knew that
naruto wouldn't go along with the plan
otherwise
how epic is this bromance both would put
the life of the other
ahead of their own kurama's last words
show concern not for himself but for
naruto he says that
now he won't have superhuman strength
anymore so he shouldn't overdo it
or he'll join him in the afterlife soon
enough kuruma implies that if they do
see each other again
it will be when naruto finally passes
away and he tells him to be
well until that day he floats away
upward a really
interesting way of signaling him passing
on it has mufasa in the clouds vibes
and finally naruto wakes up in the real
world
and wow that just happened i guess we
should have expected
someone will die after all the
foreshadowing but
i was really hoping they wouldn't
however this series is called boruto
and that means one way or another boruto
is going to have to surpass
naruto and so kurama died and naruto got
nerfed as did sasuke having lost his
renagon
an especially annoying weapon in the
eyes of the otsutsuki
in a way the nerfing was inevitable but
we didn't necessarily know
it would be this tragic however now
boruto has a clear path
to being the hero of the story the one
who will have to step up to defend the
village or even the world
at the very least we can be grateful
that naruto is still with us
and boruto is very grateful calling his
dad stupid for warring him so much
as kurma pointed out to them he did
appear to be in a death-like state
kawaki is the one who suggests that they
get back to the village at this point
sasuke points out in a stoic manner that
he can't create a portal because he lost
his rinigon
he doesn't hold boruto responsible
though he says they need to consider
themselves lucky to have survived since
they were all prepared to die
which is a good way to look at now borto
is their only way of getting back
but it isn't that easy in the meantime
though we
jump to code code is where the new god
tree
is at code is not happy with kawaki
being the chosen vessel
he looks at ishiki as if ishiki was a
god and
wanted to be the chosen one and surprise
surprise he's about to get what he
wished for in a manner of speaking the
spirit of ishiki appears
which is not new for rototsuki yushiki
explains that he did
lose and he will die however he has not
given
up he reveals that code's dud of akarma
is actually a non-vessel white
karma it's its own thing and according
to ishiki through it
his legacy lives on in the form of pure
power
he wants code to inherit the otsutsuki
will although ishiki will disappear
shortly he leaves code with the task of
feeding kawaki
or boruto to the ten tails then after
the divine tree has absorbed the life
energy on the planet and formed into a
chakra fruit
he will eat that fruit pretty standard
otutsuki stuff
then he'd become a threat to the rest of
space moving from planet to planet
devouring each along the way
the otsutsuki will is the will to keep
evolving and
ultimately become a peerless unique
existence of god
so we got those dragon ball z vibes here
where they're not just fighting for
their own village
or just for planet earth but for the
entire galaxy and universe
ishiki wants code to become a god while
code was actually a worshiper of ishiki
and viewed him as a god as a result code
will make sure to dispose of those who
stole the pillar of his heart from him
it's very poetic stuff
in other words he wants revenge against
the people who killed his god
and he wants to get it before he carries
out his larger plan
including the divine tree an interesting
twist and definitely let me know how you
guys feel about code as the next big
villain
he definitely doesn't seem like as big
of a threat after ishiki but we have to
remember that naruto and sasuke have
been nerfed
so we still can't expect this to be an
easy fight especially because of his
mysterious power upgrade and because
boruto
as we see is clearly struggling to gain
control over his powers
boruto straight up asks to be reminded
how to do space-time ninjutsu
revealing that he's still relying on
flukes rather than mastery at this point
kawaki actually ends up letting him know
that he's gotta loosen up
and it should be easy if he just relaxes
he hits the nail on the head when he
asks if boruto is worried that momoshiki
will return again
if he lets his guard down kawaki reveals
that he wanted to get rid of his karma
for good and he accomplishes thanks to
their help like a true bro
he tells boruto that he can count on
them and
that he can't expect to solve the
problem on his own in a pretty powerful
moment for kawaki
he swears that he will get rid of
boruto's karma it kind of reminds me of
naruto's promise to save sasuke in the
original series
except obviously kawaki is the more
sasuke-like character meaning he has
that tough exterior
and is more hesitant to show positive
emotions so him saying something like
this is doubly impactful the power of
friendship guys
it's the real deal kawaki's new reason
for being seems to be to help boruto
take care of his karma and to stamp out
all the other karma no matter what which
foreshadows their eventual meeting and
fight with code we get a pretty
hilarious moment where boruto asks again
how to do it and kawaki starts screaming
at him to quit
freaking out and just do it already he
throws in an idiot for good measure and
although borto snaps back at him it ends
up being the kick in the pants he needs
and finally borto succeeds in getting
the portal going
but it's very sudden and sasuke has to
react in a split second and drag naruto
with him so they don't get trapped in
this other dimension
we then jump to a model and the others
and the most significant thing here
is that they usually come cool and
collected a model looks worried af
is zoning out and is even sweating as
shikamaru tells them that naruto and the
others are back amado asks about kawaki
if he's okay he's especially relieved to
hear
that he is surprisingly this cool
scientist who usually seems emotionless
can
actually get pretty emotional and
noticeably cares a lot about kawaki
our four ninja make it back together
barely but they did it
and we have another bromantic moment
where boruto tells kawaki he feels like
anything
is possible as long as he's with kawaki
they do make quite the team and it's
crazy to think that they'll be going
head to head after the time skip but for
now boruto is clearly offering
friendship to kawaki like naruto did to
sasuke and to kurama kawaki still has to
maintain the tough guy appearance
and dodges the nice comment by telling
boruto to stand on his own already but
we and boruto know that those kind words
do mean a lot to kawaki
and the chapter finishes off with code
saying allow the names of the people
he'll make
pay who include kawaki amato sasuke
naruto and boruto again usually this
would seem ridiculous for him to take
them all on but with the recent nerfs in
power
and his own upgrade it seems like this
will be an intense battle
we quickly transition from the end of
one conflict to setting up another one
although it is related but yeah let me
know your thoughts on this chapter the
chapter that broke us
even though i predicted this might
happen i can barely believe
it actually did kurama is such an
important character and is so related to
naruto and his powers let me know your
thoughts
was this a huge mistake did you think
this was a good way for him to go
sacrificing himself for naruto and the
village
and do you think he may come back since
we don't fully know what to expect since
baryon mode
is a relatively new thing and kuroma did
say this
may be the last time they speak again
keywords maybe
we'll see what happens and i'll
definitely cover it on this channel but
it was
no doubt heartbreaking and at the same
time it was also extremely impactful
to see how far kurama has come do you
like the fact that naruto and sasuke got
nerfed giving boruto and kawaki a chance
to step
up and take center stage i have a buddy
who is a huge fan of the original naruto
and he hates to see naruto and sasuke
being nerfed
but this series is called boruto so it
was inevitable that one way or another
porto would have to surpass the others
and this gives an opening for that to
happen without the mangaka downplaying
naruto's full power
anyways that is it for this one if you
do enjoy these boruto chat reviews and
want to keep them coming then show borto
some love by smashing
that like button if you haven't be sure
to subscribe and this is crucial hit
that notification bell and select all or
you will miss future boruto videos
and while you wait for the next insane
chapter to drop
feel free to check out my growing naruto
borto playlist
where i got videos on all tutsuki all
uzumaki
all kage and much more link to that is
in the description
and i especially want to thank the
patron squad over on patreon and here on
youtube who helped make videos like this
one possible first and foremost i want
to thank
the patron of legend the one
acknowledged by lord tuigo himself
and the most donated champion of the
world alpha sigma
and are the one tier patrons the ones
who stand atop all clans
in grotto the world acquire respect but
they have a liam thompson alger tall
dr cortman johnny boy draws emperor taku
spidey life tinel baked buddhist and
tungsten tarkis and our pro hero to your
patrons the one and only gilgamesh
steelers angel crews anatoly kozlowski
joe stanton barry gucci jessica kayla
fond
rethuen de aura alicia actor bonnie
parks hinokami and water the red-haired
raven
joanne garcia jack watches anime fat boy
games ted note head deadly saint matthew
cruz and
anthony schreiber thank you all so much
if you do enjoy our work
you can support more of it by going over
to patreon.com
anime uproar and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing epic people right here and
you'll even get access to our private
patron only discord where we talk about
anime
life waifus and of course dank memes
so check out patreon.com anime upload
link to that
is in the description if you're
interested you can also join the youtube
channel by clicking that blue join
button next to the subscribe button
that you've hopefully already clicked so
yeah you can support more content that
way if you prefer
whichever way to support us you can get
the same great benefits
thanks again and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you